todo
[Música]
hola hoy en saint lips como visualizar
la relatividad general
el objetivo de este vídeo es exponer
diferentes representaciones de esta
teoría y proponer además una
interpretación gráfica novedosa la cual
no había sido establecida por nadie que
sepamos a pesar de sus cualidades
la idea de esta nueva representación es
aprovechar al máximo el formato de vídeo
y en particular su dimensión temporal
para reproducir fielmente lo que nos
dicen las matemáticas
desde la escuela primaria hasta la
secundaria aprendemos que la caída libre
puede ser modelada por una fuerza la
fuerza de la gravedad
esta fuerza nos permite predecir el
movimiento de los objetos afirmando que
se atraen unos a otros y en particular a
los cuerpos masivos como la tierra
sin embargo esta descripción es una mera
aproximación y falla cuando la atracción
es demasiado fuerte como en el caso de
la trayectoria de mercurio alrededor del
sol
fue en 1915 cuando albert eisntein
propuso una nueva teoría un modelo
matemático riguroso que permitía
describir la caída libre con mayor
precisión
para einstein no existe una fuerza que
actúe a distancia es el propio tejido
del universo el espacio-tiempo el que se
distorsiona y arrastra los objetos a la
caída
para comprender esa teoría tan compleja
es importante diseñar visualizaciones
para hacerla más asequible
la representación que más se utiliza es
la de una gran tela elástica sobre la
que se sitúan objetos masivos
al deformar la tela bajo su peso los
cuerpos más masivos atraen al resto en
su dirección como si fueran canicas en
un tazón
[Música]
a primera vista esta imagen parece tener
dos ventajas es muy sencilla e intuitiva
y nos ayuda a entender que los cuerpos
se atraen indirectamente a través de un
tejido subyacente el espacio-tiempo cuya
geometría puede alterarse
sin embargo aunque está muy generalizada
esta forma de presentar la relatividad
general tiene un gran abanico de
problemas que la hacen poco rigurosa
en este vídeo intentaremos mejorar esta
visión efectuando cuatro grandes cambios
para empezar la imagen de la tela
elástica parece indicar que los objetos
están situados sobre el espacio-tiempo
como canicas cuando en realidad el
espacio-tiempo es el tejido del universo
que los contiene
en consecuencia se puede comenzar por
aplanar los objetos sobre la superficie
de tal forma que se evidencia que no son
externos por el contrario están
contenidos en el espacio-tiempo
ahora uno de los grandes problemas de
esta representación es que de alguna
manera explica la gravedad por la
gravedad misma a la pregunta porque cae
la manzana en la tierra esta
visualización parece responder que es
porque la manzana es atraída hacia abajo
lo que hace que caiga como una canica en
un tazón
pero no se debería explicar la gravedad
dentro del espacio-tiempo utilizando la
gravedad fuera del espacio-tiempo
tenemos que encontrar una mejor
explicación
en particular es más riguroso decir que
si los objetos se desplazan siguiendo el
tazón creado por la tierra es porque se
mueven en línea recta pero en una
geometría curvada
los objetos se mueven de manera
rectilíneo pero gracias a la curvatura
del espacio-tiempo nos da la impresión
de que estas trayectorias son curvadas
para entenderlo imaginemos la superficie
de una esfera en la que dos hormigas se
dirigen hacia el norte
al principio los dos caminos son
paralelos y podríamos pensar que era
avanzar en línea recta las dos
trayectorias nunca se cruzarán sin
embargo las dos hormigas acaban
encontrándose en el polo norte esto es
posible gracias a la geometría curva de
la esfera en la que las líneas rectas
tienden a acercarse entre sí
dentro del espacio-tiempo el fenómeno es
similar y los objetos parecen atraerse
cuando simplemente siguen las líneas
rectas de una geometría curvada
sin embargo esta imagen de una tela
elástica sigue siendo engañosa en efecto
se podría pensar que si el
espacio-tiempo puede doblarse es debido
a la existencia de una dimensión
superior aquí por ejemplo la tela
bidimensional parece doblarse en una
tercera dimensión
esto no es así y las matemáticas de la
relatividad no requieren ninguna
dimensión superior para que el universo
se doble
por lo tanto es preferible no
representar esta tela vista de perfil
sino desde arriba con una cuadrícula
para ilustrar la curvatura
de paso esto también nos permite
restablecer las tres dimensiones del
espacio en que vivimos
por último el principal problema de esta
representación es que nuestro diagrama
ignora por completo la dimensión
temporal
el espacio-tiempo es un objeto de cuatro
dimensiones tres dimensiones de espacio
pero también una dimensión de tiempo que
puede igualmente doblarse y curvarse
representar fielmente una geometría
cuadri dimensional es estrictamente
imposible por lo que tenemos que
encontrar un artilugio
una primera idea sería añadir pequeños
relojes a nuestro diagrama en cada punto
de la cuadrícula
esta cuadrícula espacial se convierte en
una cuadrícula espacio-temporal y se
entiende que el tiempo puede fluir de
forma diferente según el lugar en el que
nos encontremos
dicho esto añadir relojes a nuestro
diagrama no nos ayuda mayormente y en
particular seguimos sin entender
realmente qué causa la caída de los
objetos si soltamos una manzana porque
empieza a moverse hacia la tierra
para llegar a explicarlo es necesario
eliminar una dimensión espacial para
representar la dimensión temporal
de hecho es esta última la que explica
la gravedad
con tal diagrama vemos que la manzana
está siempre en movimiento
incluso cuando no tiene ninguna
velocidad al empezar su caída la manzana
sigue moviéndose en el tiempo avanza
hacia el futuro
si no se aplica ninguna fuerza a la
manzana la curvatura del espacio-tiempo
irá inclinando su trayectoria entre una
velocidad temporal hacia el futuro y una
velocidad espacial hacia el suelo
[Música]
la manzana se mueve en línea recta pero
la curvatura del espacio-tiempo gira la
orientación de esta línea recta entre el
tiempo y el espacio
por lo tanto vemos que si la manzana cae
hacia el suelo es porque partía con una
velocidad temporal la curvatura del
espacio-tiempo generada por la tierra no
ha hecho más que convertir esta
velocidad temporal en una velocidad
espacial
ahora bien como seres humanos no
percibimos la velocidad temporal de los
objetos cuando se suelta una manzana nos
parece que está inmóvil no percibimos un
movimiento temporal
desde nuestra perspectiva percibimos el
mundo instante tras instante
y este diagrama que los objetos forman
líneas a través del tiempo conocidas
como líneas de universo no es muy
intuitivo
nuestro último paso será de esta manera
cortar este diagrama fragmentarlo
constante tras instante para formar una
animación que incluya el tiempo
[Música]
la curvatura del universo que causa la
inmersión de líneas rectas en la tierra
se convierte en un movimiento de
contracción
el ritmo de esta contracción es
constante y perpetuo por lo que la
curvatura del espacio-tiempo que solo
depende de la masa de la tierra es
siempre la misma
[Música]
sin embargo es fundamental aclarar que
la geometría no es la que se contrae es
el hecho de que las líneas rectas se
junten lo que produce esta impresión de
contracción
[Música]
el fenómeno es bastante similar en la
superficie de una esfera su curvatura es
constante pero las líneas rectas parecen
acercarse perpetuamente
esta representación es la que nos parece
más interesante para visualizar la
relatividad general
la tierra al ser muy masiva de forma el
espacio-tiempo dándole una curvatura
en nuestro caso la curvatura del
espacio-tiempo aparece como una
contracción infinita de la cuadrícula
en términos técnicos es el volumen
contenido entre las genéticas el que se
contrae con el tiempo debido a la
curvatura
esta cuadrícula en contracción
representa lo que llamamos marcos
iniciales
respecto a esta cuadrícula un cuerpo que
no esté sometido a ninguna fuerza
conservará su movimiento
así si soltamos la manzana sin velocidad
inicial al no ejercer ninguna fuerza
sobre ella permanecerá inmóvil respecto
a la cuadrícula
pero como ésta se contrae la manzana
caerá
con esta representación de la
relatividad también resulta fácil ver
que la superficie del planeta se acelera
constantemente hacia arriba ya que
siempre va en contra del movimiento
natural de la cuadrícula
por último si lanzamos un objeto es el
costado con una velocidad inicial al no
aplicarse ninguna fuerza continúa en
línea recta en la cuadrícula pero a
medida que ésta se contrae el objeto es
atraído hacia la tierra
así es como la luna órbita alrededor de
la tierra
y la tierra orbita alrededor del sol
[Música]